Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Three, Episode Four: Danish business life and trade with the rest of the world.
How does a country get from ploughs to pharmaceuticals?
Like most other wealthy countries, Denmark has gradually developed from being an agricultural society to an industrial society, and then, in the last 50 years, to being a so-called knowledge and service society.
That is, we have gone from an economy that is primarily based on the production of goods, to being to a higher degree dependent on highly educated labour, with a focus on using knowledge and getting new ideas, and on the production of services, for example the banking sector, IT support, research or education.
Until the end of the 1800s, the majority of the population worked in agriculture.
But from the 1870s, industry and crafts grew quickly, the population moved from countryside to town, and the towns grew.
Agriculture remained important, however, especially because agricultural goods made up most of Denmark's exports.
The focus was on high-quality animal production, for example meat, butter and cheese, within the framework of the many cooperative associations' dairies and slaughterhouses.
Right up until the end of the 1950s, agricultural goods made up more than half of Denmark's exports.
Agricultural production is still large, but since the 1950s there has been a dramatic increase in efficiency, and today only about two percent of the workforce work in agriculture itself.
But agriculture is still an important export industry.
People often speak in that connection of a food cluster, fødevareklynge, because fewer are employed in agriculture itself and more are employed in processing, transport, sales, marketing and product development.
Agriculture is also changing in other ways.
Agriculture has been criticised for being too efficient in an unfortunate way, among other things because too much poison is used on the fields to kill weeds, fungi and insects.
That has contributed to a beginning green transition, so that Denmark today is the country with the largest share of agriculture, 11.1 percent in 2024, run as organic farming.
Organic farming is run, among other things, without the use of chemical pesticides and artificial fertiliser, and the animals have more room in the stables and better opportunity to get out into the open air.
The first big wave of industrialisation in Denmark took place at the end of the 1800s and the beginning of the 1900s.
Progress continued, but at a somewhat slower pace, until the second big wave of industrialisation, which was from the end of the 1950s to around 1970.
From the beginning of the 1970s, the share of people employed in industry fell, just as had earlier happened in agriculture.
Instead, the service sector grew.
Today, almost four out of five people employed work in private or public service companies, for example in tourism, health, consulting or education.
About 30 percent of employees in Denmark work in the public sector.
That is roughly one third, so most employees, about two thirds, work in the private sector, not the public sector.
The production of agricultural and industrial goods has, however, risen, even though the number of employees has fallen.
That is especially due to the mechanisation of production and the rapid technological development in these sectors.
Denmark has previously been characterised by most companies being small or medium-sized.
That is still true, but more companies have come along that take up a lot of space on the world market in the industries where Denmark is especially strong.
This applies for example to food, where dairies and slaughterhouses are gathered into international giants: Danish Crown was in 2025 the world's second largest pig slaughterhouse, and Arla was in 2025 among the ten largest dairies.
Carlsberg was in 2025 the world's fourth largest brewery.
Denmark has a large pharmaceutical industry.
Several Danish pharmaceutical companies have a large share of the world market, of which Novo Nordisk is the largest.
The location of Novo Nordisk in Denmark is of very great importance for the Danish economy, exports and employment.
Denmark also makes over one third of the world's hearing aids.
The three biggest Danish producers, GN Store Nord, with GN Resound, William Demant, with Oticon, and Widex, are among the biggest hearing aid producers in the world.
In addition, LEGO is one of the world's biggest toy groups.
LEGO was founded in 1932, and is an abbreviation of "leg godt", which means "play well".
The headquarters is in Billund in Jutland.
LEGO is known for making plastic bricks.
Denmark has always been a big seafaring nation and had, in 2024, the world's tenth largest merchant fleet, and the world's second largest container shipping company in 2025, Mærsk.
Add to that companies from the green sector.
The Danish Vestas was in 2024 the world's largest wind turbine producer.
Denmark is also very strong when it comes to energy savings, which can for example be insulation or extra energy-efficient products.
Now to trade with the outside world.
Denmark has a very open economy, where trade with other countries plays a very big role.
Exports make up about half of the country's total production.
That is naturally also because Denmark is a small country, and trade with other countries, not least the neighbouring countries, therefore takes up a lot of space.
Germany is the country Denmark imports, buys, most from, and the USA is the country Denmark exports, sells, most to.
Overall, however, exports to other EU countries are clearly greater than to the USA.
In 2025, Denmark's seven biggest trading partners were the following, in their share of the value of Denmark's total foreign trade, imports and exports.
The USA, 14.1 percent.
Germany, 12.7 percent.
Sweden, 7.8 percent.
The Netherlands, 5.4 percent.
The United Kingdom, 5.2 percent.
China, 4.8 percent.
And Norway, 4.0 percent.
So measured by total trade, imports plus exports, the USA is now Denmark's biggest trading partner, ahead of Germany.
Germany is still the country Denmark buys most from, the biggest source of imports.
Older exam questions that give Germany as the biggest trading partner are out of date.
Danish governments have in modern times almost always been in favour of as much free trade between countries as possible.
Since the 1990s Denmark has also done better in international competition.
In the same period, Danish exports have in practically all years been higher than imports.
Denmark is a member of a number of international organisations that, like the EU, also work for more free trade.
This applies for example to the OECD, the Organisation for Economic Cooperation and Development, and the WTO, the World Trade Organization.
Economic globalisation has brought about big changes on the Danish labour market.
Many companies have moved parts of their production to places in the world where wages are lower.
Not only to China, but also to, for example, Eastern Europe or other European countries.
Up to now, companies have, however, typically kept some important functions in Denmark, for example the development of new products, sales and management.
In return, new big markets have also emerged for Danish products.
Here is your recap for Episode Four.
Denmark went from agricultural society to industrial society, and in the last 50 years to a knowledge and service society.
Until the end of the 1800s most people worked in agriculture; from the 1870s industry and crafts grew.
Agricultural goods were more than half of exports until the end of the 1950s.
Today only about two percent of the workforce works in agriculture.
Denmark has the largest share of organic agriculture, 11.1 percent in 2024.
Industrialisation came in two waves: the end of the 1800s, and the end of the 1950s to about 1970.
Almost four out of five employees work in services, and about 30 percent of employees in the public sector.
Danish Crown is the world's second largest pig slaughterhouse, Arla among the ten largest dairies, Carlsberg the fourth largest brewery, Novo Nordisk the largest Danish pharmaceutical company, Denmark makes over one third of the world's hearing aids, LEGO was founded in 1932 and is based in Billund, Mærsk is the second largest container shipping company, and Vestas the largest wind turbine producer.
Exports are about half of production.
Germany is the biggest source of imports, the USA the biggest export market.
The top trading partners in 2025, with the USA the biggest in total trade: the USA 14.1 percent, Germany 12.7, Sweden 7.8, the Netherlands 5.4, the United Kingdom 5.2, China 4.8 and Norway 4.0.
Denmark is a member of the OECD and the WTO.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How large a share of those in employment work in the public sector?
Option A: About one third.
Option B: About two thirds.
[DA] Hvor stor en del af de beskæftigede arbejder i den offentlige sektor?  A: Ca. en tredjedel  |  B: Ca. to tredjedele
The answer is A: About one third.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2021 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ca. en tredjedel
Question 2.
Is the majority of employees in Denmark employed in the public sector?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er flertallet af lønmodtagerne i Danmark ansat i den offentlige sektor?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 3.
Which of the following companies is known for producing wind turbines?
Option A: Novo Nordisk.
Option B: Mærsk.
Option C: Vestas.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende virksomheder er kendt for at producere vindmøller?  A: Novo Nordisk  |  B: Mærsk  |  C: Vestas
The answer is C: Vestas.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Vestas
Question 4.
Where did most people work around 1850?
Option A: In industry.
Option B: In agriculture.
Option C: In fishing.
[DA] Hvor arbejdede der flest mennesker omkring 1850?  A: I industrien  |  B: I landbruget  |  C: I fiskeriet
The answer is B: In agriculture.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: I landbruget
Question 5.
Which country does Denmark have the largest trade with, imports and exports combined, according to the 2026 edition of the learning material?
This is an updated question, because older exam keys said Germany.
Option A: China.
Option B: The USA.
Option C: Germany.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende lande har Danmark størst samhandel (import og eksport) med? [opdateret til lærematerialet 2026]  A: Kina  |  B: USA  |  C: Tyskland
The answer is B: The USA.
This is not an old exam answer: older exam keys said Germany, but in the 2026 material the USA, with 14.1 percent, is ahead of Germany, with 12.7 percent.
[DA] ✔ B: USA
That's the end of this part.
Well done.